our special guests Anthony Anderson and
marseilles Martin are here helping us
explore the differences between the
brains of kids and grown-ups Luke what
do you do for so I did tell you before
they I'm going to teach more say hard to
read Anthony's mind that's not exactly
accurate I said because it's very
difficult to read minds it's very very
complicated to do it but we're gonna
make Antony think that she's reading his
mind because it's very simple all you
need is a very good ventilation and an
earpiece in her ear and I'm gonna give
her instructions from the control room
and feather exactly what to do and she
becomes a Mentalist
I say Shh so you're gonna do all the
work but it's gonna look like she's
doing all the work oh yeah I love it
okay all right this is gonna be great
please welcome back Anthony Anderson in
Marseilles bar
so Anthony Lee or and Marseille have
planned a little surprise for you okay
yes I hope you remember everything that
I tell you to do yes just relax all
right be very positive okay are you
ready good luck I'm gonna have some
coffee and let me know how it was okay
what's the bad to happen right now I say
you can hear me just kidding need to
concentrate concentrates relax
see this and hoots behind you all right
look at the books now just pick out any
book that you want perfect just pick out
any one book and just just one book
though so just pick out any book all
right open the book any page to any page
that you want touch the books lightly
okay yeah I'm a book tell him to think
of the word from that page you selected
one word just think of a word from that
page from the page that you have that
like really means something to you okay
yes I want you to circle that word
secretly now circle the word that you're
connected with circle yes look at me and
think of your world all right now look
at me you think of you would take the
pears in the pen from the library
tell him to keep thinking of the world
now keep thinking of the word think of
the first letter I think of the first
letter is it f is it s
Yeah right big the word selfish I'm
writing something ask him what was the
word he was just thinking of and circled
what's the word that you chose hold on
let me look at it again guys selfish
let's do it again so now can you please
with the book back please yeah let's do
it again but differently let's do it
again
give him a marker and the pen you get
the marker in the pad uh-huh
I want you to go back in time all right
so I want you to go back when you were
very little very little try to think of
your first pet try to think of your
first pet do you even remember your
first time I've you okay answer a few
questions just answer a few questions
for me okay what's your favorite color
what's your favorite color red give me a
number from one to ten give me a number
from one to ten seven can you draw the
pets just droit can you draw the pet for
me like like I count like you know just
you know just draw what the pet was yes
let's do a drawing did you drive yes I
did
can I can I look can I see alright I
know it says roof roof but that's what
it sounded like what my dog was there
when he was barking I feel that he's not
with us anymore right I feel that he's
not alive anymore right
well I'm barely alive and if this is a
childhood pet okay check for you tell
him to name any any color again okay
name any color the Sun green okay tell
him are you ready are you ready I'm
ready
I'm gonna say a name I'm gonna say a
name green did the colors I just gave
you have nothing to do with the dog's
name it gave me more than you think I
think you gave me more than you think
no I didn't okay say the word chimp was
a champ
you were wish you were winch no good
chance it was chance okay
[Applause]
[Music]
you